starting tomorrow construction begins on
nellis boulevard between tropicana and
craig
bianco holman breaks down those changes
for us improvements are coming to the
east side of the valley
on monday november 9th the nevada
department of transportation will start
work on 10-mile upgrades to nellis
boulevard between tropicana avenue and
craig road
the 26 million dollar project will
create a safer and more pedestrian
friendly corridor
asphalt and street lights will be
replaced and new signs will be posted at
major intersections of sahara
charleston boulevard and bonanza road
new handicap accessible ramps
sidewalks and driveways will be
installed now all this work will happen
sunday nights through friday evenings
during construction there will be lane
restrictions so indot encourages drivers
to use caution when traveling through
the work zone
pay attention to construction signs or
take alternate routes when possible
by mid-2022 this project will not only
make the driver walk easier
it's also adding more than 300 jobs
reporting in east las vegas bianca
holman